I can tell when his he's about to poop
because his book light kind of comes out
a little bit Joyce you wanna you wanna
help no that's my boy Riku
hi I'm Salam hi I'm Joyce and today we
are going to be hand cats for you full
24 hours I'm so excited
no you're not alright when you have been
first how long we've been friends now
almost a year we're getting there and
then we started doing a lot of different
videos together and we're like man we
click you get the same ideas we thirst
over the thank you boy yes I mean well
friendship to be better than this oh I
thought that maybe Joyce and I could
withstand being and come together for
just borrowers we like each other
but there are probably definitely times
that we getting on each other's nerves
what I do that gets on your nerves I
need to know oh I do think it's on just
with a lot of high-pitched noises I
think I get annoyed when you call me at
language very annoyed when you call me
at wing even though we're friends I
don't think we get to see really what we
both do you want to write their full day
so I've been fun being cute and super
mobile day it's never big here's not a
week there I'm just worried about people
like watching us that's gonna be weird I
think everyone's gonna think we're in a
weird sex thing that's like who do you
see walking around with you
I just don't know how it's gonna work
with us together so you probably that
sounds like a you brought sounds like
you get annoyed of me quickly I don't
get annoyed quickly I hope that we are
still friends and I hope that we are
still friends after this video
lock me up mamacita oh my god I'm gonna
swallow this key no I'm just gonna throw
it we'll get it later
[Music]
yeah okay we gotta go walk my dog
Oh she'll sew up the thing dog so after
we got hearing cups we headed back to my
place because I was like well I need to
walk my dog for today the first thing
and that's seeing us to do is handcuff
people and you're being a real pain
Joyce cuz it poops a lot walking you
the dog is walking is already ready to
put choice you wanna you and a help no
thanks
thanks for being super good boy boy come
come we need to pick it up you disgust
me
let's go get lunch and then after that
we went to get say lunch yeah she took
me to a very bougie
[Music]
yeah French skinny booty shakin it was
so good I had pickles on my sandwich so
I think what was really great about this
24 hours realizing how much for me
there's not a freakin disrespect we are
chained up to me she was like okay so
I'm just trying to walk to get to the
car she walks so slow I feel like I'm
dragging you you are dragging me you're
like there we go
you're like the damn dogs everywhere we
had a lot to do that day and I had never
really noticed how slow Jory's walks so
I had to walk and I was just like
stroller
okay so Joyce randomly decided that she
wants to get her eyebrows done and we
found this place so I guess we're gonna
do it yeah we went to get our eyebrows
done randomly yeah so it was literally
the awkward thing ever because she's
laying down getting her eyebrows done
yes and she made a stake her eye and
kind of like hold her high brow centered
because they were doing threading
because she's lifting her arm but I was
literally just like this in between
Joseph's legs so my hand is just laying
hey anything to get those she actually
got this [ __ ] I got this dress you guys
it was like really cool but actually
trying on the clothes are really hard
currently she's trying to get dressed I
really like this sweater but I mean I
know this isn't gonna work I would have
also got to go do you want to try yeah
this is cute honestly I don't even know
it I don't even know why we tried trying
on the clothes I mean she wanted to that
was my idea I will take the fall for
that because that was kind of stupid
shopping trip together I love a good
shopping oh yeah where are we Joyce
we're at my light installation art show
I think it's really dope are they gonna
like it I think like wow my world is
open we're gonna go to this arch I don't
even know what this is this literally
looks like you're taking me to the
Church of Scientology so I love art
shows if you guys don't know this I have
a art Oh for real like every weekend
like before the club I like to go to an
art show because it just relaxes me and
like helps open up my mind into the
perspective of what's going on in the
world and etc so this is an immersive
park so it's about like technology and
religion which is really cool to see
like the that comedy between that but my
favorite part was
three me don't show but this was
different like when we first walked in I
was like oh god we're just gonna be
looking at art all day and so then when
we got in further it was very cool like
I actually enjoyed this I have to say I
also the nervous thing I enjoy it
because like again I did not research
the artists yeah I think that like this
was like just gave us a lot of time to
like chat because you know the [ __ ]
hand come to me I understood getting a
cup to your friend is a weird thing to
do but I think it really forced to stay
hanging out and have that friend time I
personally enjoy that day I think we
need anything out more we do yeah
actually I didn't know cuz we're close
friends but I think this is what made us
best friend but when we uncover
ourselves I was so damn heavy
oh man ish I literally took the longest
to a person that was like a whole like
day yeah I was just kind of like holding
it in as a respect emergency head buck
was like clenched
[Music]